this video is sponsored by imprint learn
about Big Ideas in Psychology philosophy
self-help and much more through
beautiful Visual and interactive content
the first 200 people to use the link in
the description will receive 20 off
their annual membership
you've just woken up you're not sure who
you are where you are or where you've
come from you look down and see only a
hazy outline of a mostly translucent
indiscernible body around you is a vast
seemingly unending white space
in front of you is a large screen on it
an icon reads build your world begin
here you press it and a window appears
revealing a list of what appear to be
features descriptions and rules for how
a world Works how the society you will
be born into will work according to you
each item on the list has a description
and the option to toggle it on or off
for some indeterminate amount of time
you read through the list and select the
conditions of the society you will live
in the laws and regulations the way
people in groups will be treated what
rights people and groups will have the
way people in groups will be aided what
will be allowed and forbade how wealth
goods and labor will be distributed and
redistributed and so on
soon realize a problem
you don't know who you will be you don't
know if you'll be black white asian
Hispanic and so on you don't know if
you'll be male or female disabled or
able-bodied you don't know what you will
enjoy you don't know what your sexuality
will be if you will be born into a high
or low income family you don't know
anything about you
you quickly determine that the best
thing you can do is ensure that the
world you create treats everyone as
fairly and as well as possible so that
no matter who you are born as even if
you're one of the worst off you will
still have a fair shot at a pleasant and
prosperous life
finish you review your work happy with
what you've created then at the bottom
of the final screen you press done
this is a version of the thought
experiment known as the veil of
ignorance or the original position which
was originally formulated by American
philosopher John Rawls in his book a
theory of Justice Rawls used this
thought experiment to illustrate a
neutral point of view that members
Founders and leaders of a society must
strive to adopt in order to evaluate and
determine Fair rules and principles
although this thought experiment does
arguably promote a very useful ideal for
how we ought to consider and strive
toward a fair and just Society a problem
that we quickly discover with it is the
apparent impossibility for anyone to
ever truly reach such a position
Rawls himself understood this to be the
case when he wrote the original position
is a purely hypothetical situation the
conception of the original is not
intended to explain human conduct except
insofar as it tries to account for moral
judgments and helps to explain our
having a sense of justice
when referring to a perspective of
balance and neutrality he continues it
is doubtful whether one can ever reach
the state
and here we arrive at our first
philosophical problem the problem of
fairness how do we Define and Carry Out
fairness in a world where everyone can
only make decisions and determine rules
and principles from bias partial
self-interested and unoriginal positions
is fairness ever really possible
not only does the veil of ignorance
bring up the problem of fairness and
justice but it also brings up the
problem of luck of course we in fact do
not know or choose who we are going to
be born as or what Society we will be
born into and so whether we are born
into a particular society as someone who
is favored or Not by said Society is
entirely luck and furthermore all the
uncontrollable events that happen to us
during our lifetime regardless of who we
are and where we are born are also a
product of luck
this brings us to our second
philosophical problem the problem of
moral luck
the term moral luck was first introduced
by English philosopher Bernard Williams
in 1976 and was then further developed
primarily by American philosopher Thomas
Nagel broadly moral luck refers to
situations in which a moral agent is
given a certain amount of moral blame or
praise for an action but the individual
did not have any control over the action
the action's consequences or their own
personal circumstances that influence
the degree of moral blame or praise that
they received
to be clear a moral agent here refers to
an individual who has the ability to
think in terms of right and wrong and
can decide to act accordingly in his
essay moral luck Thomas Nagel identifies
the following four kinds of moral luck
resultant or consequential
circumstantial constitutive and causal
situations containing resultant moral
luck are cases in which moral blame is
assigned to an individual or not based
primarily on the consequences of their
action and not merely the action itself
and the consequences were caused or not
largely by chance
for example consider two separate bars
that are down the street from each other
in the first bar there was a man named
Tom and the second there was a man named
Larry both Tom and Larry are reasonably
decent people but tonight both find
themselves in an argument with someone
else at their respective bar in both
cases the argument escalates to a
physical altercation a common bar fight
that happens countless times every day
across the world at some point in the
altercation Tom throws a punch at the
other individual and hits them in the
face the other person then proceeds to
throw a punch or two back at Tom and
then the fight is broken up by the bar
staff both Tom and the other individual
are kicked out of the bar and Tom goes a
separate way home with a couple minor
bruises and a body full of adrenaline at
the same time over in Larry's bar at
some point in his altercation he too
throws a punch at the same speed and
force with the same bar fight level
skill set as Tom and he also hits the
other individual in the face this person
however Falls backwards and hits their
head on the ground later that night the
individual is pronounced dead as a
result of the head trauma they suffered
Larry is arrested charged with
manslaughter and is sentenced to several
years in prison
both Larry and Tom committed the exact
same act but based only on the
consequences which occurred by chance
Larry is assigned significant moral
blame while Tom is assigned essentially
none
circumstantial constitutive and causal
moral luck are all relatively similar to
each other as they each refer to the
luck or Misfortune of an individual's
conditions or circumstances that either
lead them to commit an act that is
deemed moral or immoral or to receive a
different degree of moral blame or
praise compared to someone else who
committed the same act for example
specifically in the case of
circumstantial moral luck consider the
same bar situation but let's go further
down the street to a third bar where
there is a man named Marcus who has also
found himself in an argument that has
turned into a physical altercation in
Marcus's case however right as he is
about to wind up to punch the other
individual in the face the fire alarms
in the bar go off completely distracting
both Marcus and the other person and
causing the energy of the fight to
dissipate as the two are ushered outside
the bar along with the rest of the
patrons and employees Marcus was going
to punch the other individual in the
face as hard as he could but he didn't
solely because of the luck of his
circumstances
and so he receives no moral blame
whatsoever even though he had the same
intention to commit the very same act as
Larry
now let's travel to One More Bar a few
streets over in this bar we find
Stephanie a woman who is also getting
into a bar fight this night it's an
active night in Stephanie's case at some
point in the altercation she too throws
a punch at the other individual and hits
them in the face causing them to also
fall backwards and hit their head on the
ground later that night this person also
dies because of their head injury
Stephanie however receives no jail time
because while in trial it is discovered
that she was horribly and relentlessly
abused as a child and had recently been
diagnosed with severe borderline
personality disorder directly causing
her to become overly physically
aggressive and have little to no control
over her actions and so instead she is
only temporarily subject to a mental
health facility in this case Stephanie
experiences constitutive moral luck
because although her actions and
consequences are identical to Larry's
the condition of her life that caused
her to be the way she is affected or
reduced the moral blame she received
this case may seem reasonable enough
that Stephanie receives at least less
moral blame but let's go back to Larry
Larry was not abused as a child did not
experience a particularly unusual life
and is not diagnosed with any mental
illness he was just a bit tired this
night and is a bit selfish and
physically aggressive in general at
first glance Larry would seem to be the
more morally blameworthy individual but
did Larry choose to be tired and on edge
that night who would choose this did
Barry choose to be slightly selfish and
physically aggressive in general Larry
is not the original cause of Larry what
caused him to be this way was merely a
series of circumstances outside himself
that he could not control who he was
raised by what he was exposed to what
happened to him and so on as well as the
behavioral Tendencies inside himself
caused by his genetics which he also
never decided or controlled if this is
true how is Larry any more morally
responsible for being someone who got
into a bar fight that night than someone
like Stephanie according to Nagel's
Theory Larry's case includes the final
kind of moral luck or Misfortune causal
moral luck
with this in mind if moral acts by a
moral agent require the ability to
evaluate right and wrong and make
decisions accordingly can anyone truly
be morally responsible for their actions
if their actions are invariably caused
by other actions and events that were
not their own that they never had a
Saiyan or control over
of course none of this means that there
shouldn't be consequences there can and
should be but that does not negate the
prior Point consider a violent dog we
would generally not view a dog as a
moral agent and thus we would not deem a
violent dog as immoral we may determine
it best to put the dog down but at no
point would that equate to or acquire us
to assign moral blame to the dog
likewise consider a tornado certainly a
tornado is exorbitantly dangerous and if
we could contain or perhaps kill
tornadoes we would but again nowhere in
the process would we need to assign
moral blame to a tornado and so why do
we do it with ourselves are we so
conceited to think that somehow we are
the only thing separate from nature
above it the only being that can somehow
Escape what Nature has propelled forth
for us we are conscious but what formed
our consciousness
a human being wrote Albert Einstein is a
part of the whole called by us Universe
a part Limited in time and space he
experiences himself his thoughts and
feelings as something separated from the
rest a kind of optical delusion of his
consciousness
this brings us to our third and final
philosophical problem the problem of
moral knowledge what even is morality on
what are we to base it is there anything
objectively true about morality
this problem Finds Its origins in the
classic philosophical problem the is odd
problem first established by the
Scottish philosopher David Hume in the
18th century the isot problem is what
arises when one tries to make ethical
claims how the world ought to be and how
one ought to behave within it based on
facts about how the world is Hume
suggested that facts need to be combined
with ethical assumptions in order to
arrive at any sort of ethical statement
but we arrive at these ethical
assumptions solely through subjective
interpretations because on what other
basis do we have to ground and form our
interpretations
arguably we only can and do determine
moral principles through the following
methods spiritual or religious doctrines
emotional responses and science and
reason the problem is all of these rely
on assumption subjectivity or both when
deriving moral principles from spiritual
or religious sources the problem is of
course the sources in which these
spiritual or religious sources
themselves came from in order for
religious doctrines to be objectively
true the religion itself needs to be
objectively true and with what proof do
we have to conclude this the problem
with basing morality on emotions is of
course that emotions are inextricably
linked with individual subjective
perception influenced by things like our
cultural background temperament
upbringing and so on and lastly
seemingly the strongest method for
asserting moral principles is through
science and reason in his work the moral
landscape philosopher Sam Harris argues
that morality can be derived from
scientific knowledge about how the world
is because moral values are facts about
the well-being of conscious creatures
and so by understanding what actions or
events maximize the pleasure or
well-being of conscious creatures and
what actions cause harm and suffering
onto conscious creatures we can
determine objective moral truths about
good and bad
but here too Sam along with other
proponents of this Theory seem to
smuggle in an initial ought that we
ought to maximize well-being as a matter
of objective fact but on what basis is
there to ground this claim objective
means something that is independent of
our feelings and Views that would be
true with or without conscious
observation or experience how then could
the flourishment of subjective conscious
experience be a metric used in providing
objective Truth for what purpose or to
what end outside of ourselves could we
attach this metric to
ultimately there appears to be no clear
way out of the loop of is and ought
without smuggling in an odd assumption
first a claim about how reality should
be not how it is
in the end perhaps the only solution to
the problems of fairness of luck of
morality is somewhat less about finding
Perfect fairness or objective right and
wrong and more about moving forth with
an effort of understanding forgiveness
and compassion for the absurdity of it
all a sort of compassion for everyone
and everything for those who appear to
us to be good for those who appear to us
to be bad throughout history throughout
the globe and into the future
again this does not mean complacency and
total tolerance one can punish fight or
resist someone or something that they
believe is wrong while still having
compassion for the other situation in
truth none of us chose that we would be
born into this world as what and who we
are none of us set up the rules none of
us ever really had a say
but we are all here now and compassion
appears to be one of if not the only
through line that has saved us
throughout history that bolsters
positive change that accepts and
forgives the mistakes we have and will
undoubtedly continue to make into the
future
in the words of the German pessimist
philosopher Arthur schopenhauer
boundless compassion for all living
beings is the surest and most certain
guarantee of pure moral conduct and
needs no casuous tree whoever is filled
with it will assuredly injure no one do
harm to No One encroach on no man's
rights he will rather have regard for
everyone forgive everyone help everyone
as far as he can and all his actions
will bear the stamp of justice and
loving kindness
this video was sponsored by imprint for
many of us understandably our attention
spans have been at least some amount
eroded if not fully because of the
constant influx of stimulation in
today's world as a result staying
focused engaged and motivated toward
educational media that is actual
nutritional value can be fairly
difficult imprint is a completely new
way to learn that provides beautiful
Visual and interactive lessons courses
and summaries that keep you engaged in
high quality educational content in
subjects like philosophy psychology
science self-help business and more it's
perfect for those who can really benefit
from additional layers of visualization
and interactivity when learning one
really great course in particular is
essential philosophy theories and
thinkers which is an expansive course
that covers Big Ideas throughout the
history of philosophy from Socrates to
Sartre imprints expansive Content
Library includes courses and articles
from Harvard professors and best-selling
authors that can take as little is two
minutes to complete meaning you can pack
in your day during otherwise wasted
moments of mindless scrolling and
downtime with tons of information on Big
essential ideas and your favorite
subjects imprint is an easy way to feel
good about your screen time and to
constantly be learning in a way that's
fun and effective use the link in the
description below to sign up and receive
a seven day free trial the first 200
people who do will receive 20 off their
annual membership and of course as
always thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
[Music]